president Donald Trump wants to pull out
of the Paris climate Accord so this is
something that everybody is talking
about right now good I'm all for it I
just it's one of those issues where a
couple of weeks and I have no problem
praising Donald Trump for wanting to
pull out of it now by the way I was I
was in Cancun when there was a climate
summit back then it was the Kyoto
Protocol people who don't know what this
Accord exactly is that you to be the
Kyoto Protocol it was that for many many
many years and Cancun I remember was
seeing Ted Turner go up and advocate for
China's one-child policy and people
wanting to put tariffs and taxes on
energy so this the Paris climate Accord
was adopted by consensus in December
2015
signed April 2016 and went into effect
in November 2016 so it's been about a
year and pretty new yeah it's pretty new
and president Donald Trump has said you
know I don't think it's fair the United
States and I want to pull out now people
say you're a climate change denier
that's not necessarily the case a lot of
people will present this argument I
understand it they say listen if climate
change though if it is if it is real and
if it is catastrophic and imminent don't
we have to do something why wouldn't you
do something okay well let me give you a
few arguments as to why we wouldn't do
this thing this proposal would create an
average shortfall of nearly 400,000 jobs
in the United States that's over 200,000
manufacturing jobs and income loss of
more than $20,000 annually over the
course of this proposal for a family of
four GDP loss of the United States for
up to 2.5 trillion dollars and increase
in household energy expenditures by 13
to 20 percent so this also
disproportionately asks Americans to
curb and pay for the world's carbon
emissions specifically it asks for
Americans America India and China are
the ones that they climber the biggest
you know carbon emitters but then if you
look at the list of people who fledged
the most amount the United States right
at the top China
nowhere on that list none yeah I'll get
right on that
you expect these other third world
countries who'd have no EPA's they
couldn't care less about environmental
regulations to play haven't even playing
that alongside the
say so what ends up happening it ends up
hurting the United States economy and as
with everything else for the world's
greatest peacekeeping force we're the
world's greatest humanitarian force they
want us to foot the bill for everybody
else's carbon emissions and here's
what's so tits so telling there is
almost a direct correlation between
carbon emissions and advancement in
technology and innovation and thank God
for the United States and there in Vann
sment and innovation and this bill would
disproportionately harm the American
populace it's the term globalist has
been thrown around so flippantly it's
lost all meeting this is a globalist
bill with other foreign governments
having the right to mandate to create
sanctions and tell Americans what they
can and can't do with their economy with
their energy this bill is basically
asking the United States economy to just
bend over and take it
we we
[Music]
right
we feel horny
[Music]
I'm Gary Wilson on after this to discuss
the negative ramifications of
pornography that's the time to show you
signed up for what we're talking I was
on watching CNN this morning and they
were talking about green energy jobs and
it was telling because someone was
talking about you know how we need to
access all of our energy resources right
now whatever that's with fracking coal
and someone on there I don't know who it
was was a DNC strategy something I think
Elizabeth granholm was on there as well
and they said well you know what that's
not this is this is a lie from President
Trump he's promising to bring back jobs
he couldn't possibly call there aren't
enough coal jobs most jobs have gone to
green energy to solar to wind crap
stupid we had a president who put
moratoriums who said he had no problem
with putting the coal industry out of
business while simultaneously
subsidizing green energy renewable
energy that doesn't work Solyndra and by
the way is opposed by Democrats because
Ted Kennedy doesn't didn't want to have
windmills outside of his country homes
so yeah it's an it's remarkable how many
jobs will be lost in a sector that you
crippled through government intervention
while simultaneously using our tax
dollars to pay for other sources of
energy regardless of market well in
Germany the government decided to force
the economy into green renewable forms
of energy solar wind what happened well
guess what if there's not enough solar
power if there's not enough wind power
they don't have giant generators so they
can harness this power and keep it for a
long for an entire country for entire
cities so what they would have is they
would have droughts when they didn't
have enough wind or solar and then when
they would have a surplus of wind or
solar they would have to sell their
energy at negative price points where
they're actually losing money it is
incredibly unreliable oh and by the way
the carbon emissions are still up
surprise we know the negative effects
that this specific bill would have on
the United States that's why Americans
America first by the way doesn't mean
America by its lonesome someone in the
Trump campaign actually said that
recently I thought that's a good way to
put it not sure um but we're not a
global community that's just not
accurate we still are a world with
borders and countries and you do need to
look out for your own countries but you
don't think China is there's a reason
they haven't pledged anything
not because it's not because you caught
them at the wrong time write it for the
Jerry Lewis telethon okay you shake them
down you're gonna find some yen coming
out of their pocket or that crappy
friend you owes you money and just never
gets around it's like oh yeah it gets
you back so let's get into the negative
consequence is not for the United States
well in the first world it's
inconvenient in the third world that can
be deadly 15% of the world's population
that's 1.2 billion people still have no
access to electricity at all and they
have no capability of getting it through
green energy sorry rich white privileged
gender studies feminist who wants to
change quantum physics because it's
oppressive these people these over a
billion people in the world just need
energy to not die and they can't do it
with your Don Quixote window cinema
Tesla yeah well I was in Cancun like I
said we went to the actual villages and
can't come to see how people lived we
got out of the resorts they was it there
was um
Copenhagen Cancun I think I don't know
if was Paris and they said a recent
summit at NYU they always go to the cool
cities right like you're going to the
worst area of Tijuana to meet about
climate change we we need to see how the
places have been ravaged now now we're
going to a Cancun report the people we
went to a village and we saw it like you
know there was a person there who would
work all week just to have enough energy
just have enough fuel to light of fire
so that they could heat a can of beans
on a dirt floor in their house over an
ironing board over a trash can you think
they can afford doubling your energy
prices I something that a lot of people
forget about something else a production
of biofuels rich white guilt seems
really good it's actually led to at
least 192 thousand additional deaths the
last time we ran these numbers in 2010
because the crop is not being used to
produce food but energy because if
government mandates by the way energy
that often is not super efficient so if
you look at the worst estimates from the
World Health Organization they estimate
the 141 thousand people die annually
because of manmade climate change and
that's a very generous estimate so even
if you just add numbers more people are
dying in the third world because you are
preventing them from having their own
industrial revolution think about that
there was some other foreign government
who told the United States no no you
cannot have the Industrial Revolution if
they said sorry sorry mr. Ford no
automobile sorry no internet
sorry no note no factories sorry we're
not gonna allow you to make things more
efficient there would be reunited States
of America we wouldn't be able to
broadcast this right now with with
equipment by the way that only three
years ago would have been reserved for
the singularly most professional
expensive studios in the world mistake
but the math they say you're at your
climate denier listen no one here denies
the idea of climate change okay uh I
don't know anyone here who even denies
that humans have an effect on the
overall climate on planet Earth the
question comes down to is climate change
a catastrophic event which is imminent
and is there anything that we can do to
stop it if that were the case if so what
are the direct effects of the Paris
climate Accord how would that stop this
earth from warming one degree over the
next hundred years although actually
remember NASA said in the next 50 years
gonna drop half a degree then go up a
degree what would this do because we're
gonna give up hundreds of thousands of
jobs and will potentially kill millions
of people in the long term in third
world countries preventing them to
thrive through innovation and energy
because you know paying an extra I don't
know two three fold for your gas for
your groceries for anything that
requires energy or transportation here
in the first world yeah it's cost
prohibitive it's annoying it's
inconvenient it will plunge people into
the depths of extreme poverty kind of
like you see with Venezuela but it's not
deadly
in the third world it kills people from
the full show Daily Show at alotta with
credit calm slash mug Club words
available exclusively 69 dollars a year
that's less than $6 a month less than
two expensive cups of coffee or you can
feed an African child but boy just buy
coffee or join the mug club Daily Show
ladder with credit.com slash mug club
see you there don't feed children